merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des Outre-mer au nom du groupe démocrate
je tiens à vous exprimer nos plus
profonds remercions
Viking on autorisant l'accueil de ce
bateau dans le port de Toulon et de ses
234 migrants vous avez tout simplement
fait œuvre d'humanité ce qui devrait
être pour tous ici le sens de notre
engagement
avoir entendre ou lire les déclarations
les plus odieuses de ces derniers jours
de cette séance je mesure la difficulté
à laquelle le gouvernement a été
confronté mais par votre décision la
France a honoré le mot fraternité qui
est inscrit sur le fronton de toutes les
mairies
si l'affaire de la chaîne Viking est
particulièrement symbolique elle n'est
que le reflet d'un problème beaucoup
plus large
avec la multiplication des conflits aux
portes de l'Europe en Afrique au
Moyen-Orient avec le drame du
réchauffement climatique avec un écart
considérable de richesse entre les deux
rives de la Méditerranée les flux de
migrants ne sont pas prêts de ce tarif
malgré les coups de menton de certains
le refus d'accueillir un bateau par
exemple ne dissuadera aucun migrant de
tenter sa chance avec son lot de drame
nous devons donc adopter une stratégie
d'une autre dimension sur le sujet de
l'immigration à la fois sur sa
régulation mais aussi sur son humanité
la réponse européenne n'est clairement
pas à la hauteur car elle laisse trop
seul les pays du sud de l'Europe
dans ce contexte monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous nous expliquer de quelle
façon les migrants de la chaîne Viking
vont-ils être accompagnés dans les
prochains jours et nous dire quelle
stratégie le gouvernement va porter sur
la question des drames migratoires
la Méditerranée ou la Manche ne peuvent
être plus ne peuvent plus être d'immens
cimetière je vous remercie